EXPECTING THE BIGGEST BORDER
SURGE IN DECADES.
THEY ARE SAYING THIS, SECRETARY
MAYORKAS SAYS THIS -- WE ARE ON
PACE TO ENCOUNTER MORE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE SOUTH WAS
BORDER THAN WE HAVE IN THE LAST
20 YEARS BUT THE SITUATION WE
ARE CURRENTLY FACING IS A
DIFFICULT ONE.
YOU THINK SO?
WHAT DO THE BORDER COMMUNITIES
SEEN ON THE GROUND?
LET’S BEGIN SHERIFF MARK LAM
FROM ARIZONA FOR IT FIRST,
SHERIFF, WHEN PEOPLE SAY THIS IS
AS BAD AS IT’S BEEN YOU BEEN
DOING THIS JOB FIVE YEARS COULD
YOU PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE?
>> OH YEAH, THIS IS AS BAD AS IT
BAD AND WORSE THEN THE OBAMA
DAYS.
IT’S LIKE THE WILD WEST OF THERE
IN THE DESERT ON THE SOUTH END
OF OUR COUNTY.
WE ARE BACK TO THAT AGAIN WHERE
WE CAN GO OUT ALMOST EVERY TIME
WE GO OUT WE ARE FINDING 20
PEOPLE.
LAST NIGHT AND THINK WITH 49
APPREHENSIONS IN MY COUNTY.
THIS IS JUST LIKE IT WAS BACK IN
THE OBAMA DAYS, PROBABLY WORSE
AND ON TARGET TO BE WORSE.
BRIAN: THINK ABOUT THIS SHERIFF,
WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT COMING INTO
THE MALL AND GETTING
ENCOUNTERING SOMEONE WITHIN
6 FEET OF US AND NOT WEARING A
MASK.
ARE THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
DRIVING WITH RAPID TESTS?
>> NO, NO, THEY ARE NOT BEING
TESTED.
NOW WE’VE GOT SOME FIVE-PAGE
E-MAIL TELLING US HOW IT’S NOT A
CRISIS AND HOW THEY WILL DO A
BETTER JOB OF TRYING TO GET
THESE PEOPLE TESTED BUT LOOK,
THEY ARE NOT BEING TESTED IN
COMING IN HERE WITH WHO KNOWS
WHAT AND THEN WE ARE HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THEM IN OUR COUNTIES
AND IT’S UNFAIR.
AT THE SAME TIME WE’RE TELLING
BUSINESSES AND KIDS THEY CAN’T
GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND CAN’T OPEN
THEIR BUSINESSES BUT WE ARE
OPENED OUR BORDERS AND LETTING
PEOPLE COME IN UNCHECKED.
IT’S RIDICULOUS TO ME.
BRIAN: BY THE WAY, LET’S HAVE
THE NUMBERS BACK UP YOUR WORDS.
RIGHT NOW, LOOK IN FEBRUARY,
OVER 100,441 AND 221 THAT’S UP
20% FROM THE PREVIOUS MONTH,
134% COMPARED TO FEBRUARY 2020
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SAID THERE WAS A SURGE
BEFORE HIM IN PAST YEARS.
PUTTING IT IN PERSPECTIVE HOW
BAD IS THAT?
>> WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS
CONTINUE TO DO THE BLAME GAME.
THEY WANT TO BLAME PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER DENIED WE
HAD AN ISSUE AT A CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE WERE TRYING TO FIX IT AND
BUILDING THE WALL IN DOING THESE
THINGS BUT NOW WE SENT A MESSAGE
TO THE WORLD THAT WE HAVE OPEN
BORDERS AND WE ARE NOT STOPPING
PEOPLE AND NOT WE ARE PAYING THE
PRICE FOR IT.
THEY’RE SENDING UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND THE CARTEL KNOWS WHAT
OUR POLICIES ARE AND THAT’S WHY
WE ARE COMING TOGETHER AS
SHERIFF SPIRIT I STARTED AN
ORGANIZATION TO PROTECT AMERICAN
NOW AND YOU CAN CHECK IT OUT,
PROTECT AMERICA NOW .COM, WE ARE
FIGHTING TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BRIAN: YOU ARE, LOOK AT THESE
NUMBERS INTO SONGBIRD OF 45%
WITH UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
IN YUMA UP ONE OF 4%, SINGLE
ADULT ENCOUNTERS OF 260% IN
YUMA, PEOPLE COME DOWN AND LOOK
OR DON’T SHOW UP LIKE PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS NO PLANS TO GO DOWN
AND YOU HAVE TO LIMIT LIVE IT
EVERY DAY AND LIVING IT EVERY
DAY AND HAVING IT IGNORED HAS
GOT TO MAKE EVERYTHING WORSE.
>> IT DRIVES US CRAZY.
I’VE EXTENDED THE OFFER AND I
WILL DO IT AGAIN TO ANY
CONGRESSMAN OR WOMAN OR SENATOR
WHO WANTS TO COME DOWN TO SEE
THE PROBLEM FIRSTHAND.
PLEASE, COME DOWN AND SEE IT SO
YOU CAN VOTE WITH ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT IS GOING ON
BECAUSE TRULY THEY ARE VOTING
AND TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
BRIAN: SHERIFF, WHAT BOTHERS ME
SO MUCH IS TO SEE SOME OF THAT
BARRIER, THE FENCE, THE WALL
BUILT IN THE HUGE GAPS AS IF
EVERYONE WAS TOLD DROP YOUR
HAMMER, DROPPED THE TRACTOR AND
GO HOME.
WE PAID FOR THIS ALREADY AND
JUST FOR PURE POLITICAL
PURPOSES, BECAUSE SENATOR JOE
BIDEN VOTED FOR THE SECURE FENCE
ACT IT IS NOT COMPLETED.
>> THEY LITERALLY JUST TOLD THE
CREWS TO GO HOME.
I’VE TALKED TO A LOT OF THE
WORKERS.
FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT THEY
LOST THEIR JOBS AND THOSE
FAMILIES WERE PUT OUT OF WORK
AND THEY STOPPED IT IN, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THE CARTEL KNEW THAT AND
THEY STARTED BUSTING PEOPLE AND
LEFT AND RIGHT.
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IS AN
EXTREME AMOUNT OF PEOPLE AND
THERE IS NO WAY, THINK ABOUT
THAT, THEN HANDLING THAT AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE ON THE BORDER,
ESPECIALLY UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
IN THE CARTEL IS MAKING SO MUCH
MONEY OFF OF THIS.
LET’S NOT FORGET THE DRUGS.
LAST WEEK WE HAD A 12-POUND
HEROIN SEIZURE AND IT’S GOING.
BRIAN: SHERIFF, KEEP FIGHTING.
WE WILL KEEP THE SIRENS ON AND